do you think some of the stuff that uh
happens uh
with the military to toughen uh them up
do you think
it's not because you know some people
talk to you say well the method of war
has changed so much that all of those
things that rah-rah you know toughen
people up it's not necessary today you
know because
today it's more about you know maybe a
gentler approach to toughen soldiers up
we don't need to do that anymore today
it's more of a cyber warfare today it's
more about not necessarily getting up
there on the front enemy lines you know
you need to toughen soldiers up in a
different way or do you believe
no we still need to train our soldiers
to be tough because the enemy is
training their soldiers to be tougher
than us
what is your uh
thoughts on that oh yeah did you see
that uh the video went around a few
months ago that showed the uh russian
airborne commercial comparing it to
ourselves
oh my goodness yeah well yeah that [ __ ]
that should tell everybody everything
they need to know there um and the part
of adapting looking at what you do on
the battlefield we have 20 years of data
right now
incorporating those aspects into our
training very smart but the other side
is that uh we're talking about
adaptability that cyber warfare piece
yeah maybe those guys don't need to be
doing what we're doing at seals because
they're fighting a different battle
space they're right here just like i
have no idea how to fight in that space
unless they said
go to difficult location and destroy
said physical location like that's where
i excel uh but getting in there and the
different levels of the internet and i'm
doing all this research for my my new
novel that's coming out next year and
i'm looking at the cyber warfare piece
and the quantum computing piece and the
levels of the internet and where these
future battles might be fought well they
might be fought there but there's also
that chance of an electromagnetic pulse
that shuts that stuff down and here we
are we're back to fighting so fighting
oh there's always that primal that's the
one thing that hasn't changed since the
beginning of time is that primal nature
of combat that uh that visceral uh
man-to-man person to person in the
trenches that part has stayed fairly
much i mean as things have evolved
technology-wise you still it still
becomes a person against another trying
to kill one another that part has stayed
the same so you have to keep up with the
technology keep up with the tactic
techniques procedures keep learning
about your enemy so you can better
counter that enemy so you can better
translate if you're a leader some of the
uh directors coming down from higher
authority so you can get the job done uh
there at the tactical level but it's
really comes down to you putting another
human in the ground and that part has
not changed do you think we're tougher
today with our training than we were 20
years ago or
if we're not what's the consequence of
the direction we're going today
yeah uh so yeah i got out right before
all that stuff started to change
so i think by the time i got out in 2016
we were doing a very good job of
incorporating lessons learned from
downrange uh a lot of the medical stuff
had uh evolved quite a bit uh over the
years because we just had so much
learning so much we learned so much just
on the ground in the in the battle space
um so that part we were doing a good job
of incorporating that into the pipeline
into the training um but when you let
off the gas a little bit to take a take
a breath which is fine to find to do
just to make sure you're on the on the
right path but then if you want to just
become more inclusive because of uh some
sort of an equity of outcome type of uh
that that's going in the wrong direction
uh i think and that will be uh our
downfall and interesting in that last
book that i wrote i put myself in the
enemy's shoes so i spent about a year
and a half looking at the united states
through the eyes of iran
of russia of north korea of china and
what was terrifying to me is that by the
time i got done with that
year writing that book looking at us
from the enemy's side
my i had to make some adjustments to my
novel because i thought you know what if
i was the enemy we're doing a pretty
good job of destroying ourselves from
the inside right now and i could just
take back if i'm china russia there's no
need to rush uh if i'm those countries i
can take a step back take a breath and i
can just watch us do what we're doing to
ourselves from the inside this discord
that is perpetuated by a lot of the
social media type of algorithms uh that
worked for advertising well guess what
yeah they also work for political
parties uh and they work for uh
galvanizing your base and getting
support and raising money and that that
sort of a thing so um it was it was
disheartening i guess uh to say the
least that if i was the enemy i might
just watch us for a little bit um
because we're doing a lot of their jobs
for them unfortunately so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye